hi I'm Erik Bosse and Captain Marvel
released new trailer footage with some
very interesting clues into what could
go down in this movie and more fun ways
that could connect to Avengers endgame
and the guardians of the galaxy whether
she's punching through spaceships or
through old lady faces it's always a joy
to try to figure out why Captain Marvel
so pissed off so let's break down this
footage for the new details that you
might have missed in spoiler warning
case that revealed to my drone you're
like alright let's watch the first clip
from the Superbowl trailer doctor so you
boys how you do it you ready
higher further faster baby yes
faster
okay first we get a clip of Carol
Danvers and fellow Air Force pilot Maria
Rambo exchanging this higher further
faster catchphrase
they're both test pilots at Edwards Air
Force Base in Southern California flying
some experimental government aircraft
perhaps this is what leads to Denver's
encounter with alien vessels and
eventually her getting her powers now
Maria Rambo's callsign is
photon and she is the mother of Monica
Rambeau who is a major hero in the
Marvel Comics going by the name Photon
in later spectrum and in another TV
promo that came out we actually see
young Monica Rambeau
so this scene is presumably later in the
movie after Carol Danvers returns to
Earth from her time as a Kree warrior
reconnecting with Maria and getting an
over daughter Monica whom we can assume
will play a bigger role as an adult with
the Avengers in a future Marvel film
there's know some more of these rise up
shots that have been part of past
Captain Marvel trailers with a new one
added Carol rising during some air force
ceremony or hearing graduation maybe
there's also some shots of her in the
middle of a dogfight with the alien ship
either Kree are scroll now I speculate
in the past that Danvers could be
interfering in a conflict between these
two iliyan empires leading to a crash
that accidentally exposes her to some
tech that gives her her powers leading
to Yan raagh abducting and recruiting
her to be part of his crease star force
let's move on to the next section
try to keep up okay after some more
flashback shots of Carol as a girl and a
go-kart we see this shot of Talos the
scroll impostor posing as a human agent
and shield also recently Marvel released
a clip of Carroll's chase sequence in LA
hunting down a runaway scroll
shapeshifter on a train this is the one
who turns into the old woman that she
gets in a fight with no it's hard to
tell but that scroll does kind of look
like Talos though when another shiny
kind of looks like a younger guy maybe
it could be bit menace and stunt double
or maybe Talos is in the process of
shape-shifting into someone else maybe
Carol Danvers after being intercepted by
shield agents Fury and Coulson comes
face to face with another SHIELD agent
Talos and she recognizes him as a
squirrel in disguise chewing up the
restaging of the scene from Austin
Powers that I'm pretty sure this is all
clearly based on that's not your mother
it's a man baby now there's another shot
of Jude Law's character with the Star
Force and Nick Fury walking past some
shelves containing archives this kind of
looks like the area where we've seen
Danvers pouring through her old Air
Force records learning about her past
that it seems like the Kree wiped from
her memory there's also this quick shot
of Danvers honor Star Force mission
maybe the opening mission of the movie
apparently underwater very cool now in
these days the Kree refer to her as just
vers cool and we couldn't even closer
look at the way vs. helmet assembles
around her head and I pointed this out
before but this looks like the same type
of technology that star-lord uses for
his helmet and actually now that I
mentioned it I do remember Peter Quill's
specifically mentioning a run-in with
the Kree in the guardians of the galaxy
right here at Kree girl tried to rip out
my thorax she caught me with this skinny
little Oscar Marion who worked in Nova
records I was trying to get information
I assumed James Gunn meant for this Kree
girls story to just be a joke but what
if this Krieger was VIRs Carol Danvers
Captain Marvel star-lord Captain Marvel
hook up confirmed I mean the timeline
could have worked out Peter quill got
abducted by the Ravagers in 1988 roughly
around the same time Carol would have
left earth and started with the Kree and
yes something about carol's new powers
definitely keeps her from aging at a
normal speed so that may be some time
later
they could have hooked up shared some
technology and then gotten in a nasty
fight after she caught him cheating on
her with a osku Varian I guess I don't
need any game to go too much into this
but man I would love just a quick little
moment where star-lord and Captain
Marvel do it double take out each other
well first good to see you again it was
just business let's move on we see quick
shot of Nick Fury with Danvers in the
cockpit of this prototype Quinn jet here
is squinting pretty hard here careful
man staring and it's not gonna be really
bad for your vision last time I trusted
someone I lost an eye
that's why pilots wear aviators Nick now
there's a similar new shot in this
footage that actually could reveal a
major element of this movie story but
before I get to that this video is
sponsored by expressvpn a VPN allows you
to browse the internet with privacy
without things like ad companies or
hackers spyware any of these creepy
shadowy things tracking your data and
secretly filtering your Internet
experience expressvpn masks your IP
address to make sure you aren't being
monitored so that you can have peace of
mind you can live life knowing no one's
beeping on you expressvpn
is the fastest VPN on the market and the
number one VPN service rated by tech
radar and if you happen to be in
different countries around the world
like you might not be able to access
everything on Netflix or YouTube or
other streaming services that you use
but thanks to express VPN you can avoid
these weird restrictions and just watch
everything you would want to normally
the way the Internet should be wherever
you are
expressvpn lets you securely stream or
download content from anywhere anytime
it's less than seven dollars a month
with a 30-day money-back guarantee take
back your internet privacy today and
find out how you can get three months
free by clicking on the link in the
description box expressvpn comm slash
new rock stars
that's exp ress VPN comm slash new rock
stars for three months free with a
wooden your package visit expressvpn
slash new rock stars to learn more take
back your internet privacy
today okay back to Captain Marvel
there's a shot from that other promo
that shows Captain Marvel in another
cockpit riding shotgun and look behind
her that grain skin that definitely
makes this person look like a scroll in
their pre-shape shifting form maybe this
could be her prisoner but it doesn't
look like that scroll is really strapped
down other than the seat harness this
could be more evidence that Captain
Marvel might reveal the scroll as less
evil than they've been made out to be in
the Cree to be secretly more
manipulative the real big bad of this
story
assuming Jude Law's character's name is
Yan raagh John rabe is the recurring
villain of Captain Marvel in the comics
and here he's the commander of the Kree
Star Force that's not a good sign
and if speculated that a net Bennet's
character could be a representation of
the Kree supreme intelligence from the
comics a heartless AI that an axe
genocide on its own people
perhaps this here is a mission with
Captain Marvel's switching sides or
playing both sides temporarily teaming
up with a scroll to expose the truth
about the Kree and lastly there's this
amazing shot of Captain Marvel having on
binary shooting up in the sky and
punching through a ship now I'm not sure
what is a Kree array scroll craft
someone said the pointed end design
resembles the Nova Corps ships like him
Alana was I would love for a third
extraterrestrial empire to try to get
involved in this conflict between the
Korean the scroll and Captain Marvel to
just be like all you a-holes can get the
hell off my planet or maybe the ship
reminds Carroll of quills Milanoo she's
trying to rip out its thorax
we know that Ronan and Korath will also
be part of this movie so here's my
question for you guys what other
guardians of the galaxy characters would
you like to see cameo and Captain Marvel
a young Peter quill
yondu rocket Groot comment down below
with your thoughts and follow me on
twitter and instagram @ e a vas and
subscribe to this channel and subscribe
to our new podcast where every list of
podcasts specifically if you use the
Himalaya app we'd love if you subscribe
to that because Himalaya will help us
make new fun shows for you guys thanks
for watching and is that Kree girl the
messy backstory and she's gone binary
she looks pissed I got a run